China's not doing as good as people
think this whole concept of the one
child family that they did they
backfired on them because they're
getting older people are leaving they're
not even sticking around anymore
billionaires are leaving job creators
are leaving that thing's about to
collapse is it a real threat as it was
before are they getting weaker what are
your thoughts on China it's the greatest
existential threat
um this country in the world faces I
started writing about this back in 2006
I wrote a Trilogy of books that come in
China Wars
um death by China Crouching Tiger the
first two books were about the economic
threat the last book was about the
military threat without giving any
secrets away I can tell you that
whatever I said about China
in my books is far worse